(relaxing music)
- I live in Palo Alto California,
and it's a bizarre thing, I think,
for people here to build
things, physical things.
Uh, most folks are doing dot-coms.
It's kind of Neverland in Palo Alto,
and so anything is possible.
My name is Chris Robinson,
and for four or five years
I've been working on
building the Tsunami ball.
It's designed to survive
an inland tsunami.
March 2011, there was an earthquake
off the shore off of Sendai in Japan,
which caused a tsunami to basically
smash against the eastern seaboard.
When the tsunami happened,
I was at this incubator in Mountain View,
and I was watching live footage
of people trying to escape.
And the entire office
just starts discussing
how they would fix that or solve that.
And I decided then, well,
you could very simply
just put them in like a ping pong ball.
Like, a sphere is a very strong shape,
and so you could usher your family into,
and they would float around
and they would be safe.
And so I started just kind
of modifying the designs,
and at some point, I just
extruded the shape of it
and now it's a capsule.
Almost everything I'm doing
here is brand new to me.
I made mistakes from day one.
And this was this piece
that I custom designed
to be super strong,
and it's massively thick, right,
it's four inches think.
But yeah, it twisted and
just snapped in half.
So this is what happened
when the boat fell on me.
You just hope that you survive
the mistakes long enough
so that you can make progress,
um, and then you can, you can learn.
The idea is that we'll
have electric motors,
solar panels on the outside and batteries,
and you'll be able to
navigate from the boat.
So it's not gonna be a speed boat,
but you'd be able to navigate your way
wherever you need to go,
back to shore or help
somebody else that needs help.
So we kind of share the same ideas
about how to evaluate someone's project,
and it's usually based on
intelligence or money, time.
And on those three things,
this is the dumbest
project you could ever do.
And so I just think of it as an adventure.
I'm excited every day that
I'm out here working on it.
The importance is just building it.
(chiming music)